je le connais et de patty compliqué que
c'est à son mot de passe
c'est pas bon ça une tentative de
connexion à mon compte mail je ne sais
pas si vous avez déjà reçu ce genre d'
alerte mais moi j'aime pas beaucoup ça
va vous montrer comment créer des mots
de passe vraiment sécurisé repéré mes
mails frauduleux et protégez vos
smartphones et vous allez voir pas la
peine d'être une ou un crack en
informatique
[Musique]
la cybersécurité nous concerne tous par
ce mot on entend toutes les mesures de
protection de nos appareils numériques
des données qui y sont stockées et plus
généralement la sécurité de toutes nos
informations personnelles en ligne cette
protection est crucial pour les
entreprises et les états qui ont les
informations stratégiques à sauvegarder
mais ce n'est pas qu'une affaire de pros
nos données privées intéresse aussi les
escrocs en tous genres alors moi je rien
à cacher c'est pas la question de la
même façon qu'un voleur peut dérober
notre portefeuille un cybercriminel peut
piocher dans notre compte en banque ou
faire des achats à notre place usurper
notre identité consulter des photos
personnelles et le pire c'est qu'on ne
s'en rend pas toujours compte nos
données peuvent aussi tout simplement
être revendus à des fins de ciblage
publicitaire
les cybercriminels utilisent la plus
grande faiblesse des systèmes
informatiques modernes les humains
et oui vous et moi sommes les maillons
faibles dans cette histoire l'attak la
plus courante porte un drôle de nom le
phishing ou hameçonnage en français il
s'agit de messages frauduleux qui
prennent souvent l'apparence d'une
demande officielle et qui vise à nous
soutirer des informations
confidentielles comme des identifiants
de connexion ou de l'argent le nombre de
ces arnaques a doublé ces dernières
années on compte aujourd'hui 600 milles
tentatives de phishing par semaine en
france tenez rien que ce matin j'ai reçu
ce mail
apparemment de l'assurance maladie il a
l'air comme ça tout à fait officielle
avec son beau logo mais j'ai un petit
doute que je vais l'imprimer et je vais
le montrer une experte
[Musique]
alors j'ai reçu ce mail un mail qui m'a
été envoyé apparemment par l'assurance
maladie que je m'attendais pas le
recevoir ça me semble un peu bizarre
quand même est ce qu'il y a des éléments
qui doivent alerter suite la première
chose c'est le ton du mail il est très
stressant te pousse à agir très vite
sinon il va se passer des choses graves
donc on voit bien bonjour veuillez
mettre à jour votre carte vitale déjà
c'est un ordre pour continuer à utiliser
nos services il va se passer quelque
chose il y aura plus de services de
cartes vitale absolue alors ça continue
cette mise à jour doit se faire
annuellement par ses bénéficiaires
évidemment nous aimerions nous revoir
cliquez simplement sur remettre à jour
pour mettre à jour vos informations
personnelles et continuer à profiter de
tous les avantages sous-entendu si vous
ne le faites pas vous perdez vos
avantages ou le stress le gêneur ce type
de médecins tout à fait le but de ce
message c'est de vous mettre en
situation de stress pour court circuiter
votre réflexion votre esprit critique
tout de suite il faut y faire très
attention et prendre le temps de bien
analyser tous les détails du met alors
en fait il faut faire tous linverse de
ce que l'on recense dire c'est stressant
et bien au contraire il faut se reposer
et là on va aller un peu plus loin
parfois il arrive aussi qu'on reçoive
des messages nous indiquant qu on a
gagné à une loterie que si on clique sur
le lien
dans les dix minutes où l'heure qui
vient on va gagner le dernier smartphone
par exemple généralement quand c'est
trop beau pour être vrai c'est que c'est
pas vrai dans tous les cas il ya une
urgence il ya une notion d'urgence pour
vous pousser à agir vite c'est
effectivement là qu'il faut prendre un
peu de recul alors on prend du recul et
que ce qu'on fait par exemple la
première chose c'est qu'on va regarder
un petit peu leur tour graff on se rend
compte quand on regarde de plus près
qu'il ya des petits soucis votre carte
vitale sans eux ça attire vite l'oeil
c'est pas tout à fait normal dès le
premier mot veuillez mettre à jour le il
n'est pas à la bonne place ses
bénéficiaires il manque un ace ensuite
l'autre chose à laquelle il va falloir
prêter attention c'est l'expéditeur et
on va certainement se rendre compte que
ça n'est pas une adresse officielle
peut-être un expéditeur qui vient d'un
autre pays belgique allemagne ou autre
ça n'est pas très crédible pour une
administration française voilà et puis
on peut aussi aller sur le site de
l'administration qui nous envoie le
message commence ici l'assurance maladie
et essayer de voir si on a un problème
pas tout à fait évidemment surtout pas
en cliquant sur le lien contenu dans les
mails mais si on a un doute dans ces cas
là on peut se rendre sur le site dont on
pense que vient email le site de
l'assurance maladie en l'occurrence
surtout par votre lien habituel et là
vous verrez bien ce qui se passe s'il ya
devait y avoir un problème on vous le
signaleur mais surtout surtout ne jamais
cliquer sur le jamais cliquer sur un
lien que ce soit pour gagner un
smartphone gagner à la loterie mettre à
jour une information vitale surtout on
va toujours sur les sites par les accès
que l'on connaît déjà alors ça c'est ce
qu'il ne faut pas faire des ce qu'il y a
des choses à faire au contraire est-ce
que ce type de message peut être signalé
vous pouvez le signaler notamment à la
plateforme pharos cet incident du
gouvernement cyber games point gouv.fr
vous pouvez copier le lien surtout sans
cliquer mais le copier et leur signaler
ils s'occuperont de demander la mise en
ligne du site et puis tout ce que l'on
décrit concernant les mails que l'on
peut recevoir c'est aussi valable pour
les sms absolument et pirates on voit
aussi des sms avec le même ton un petit
peu d'urgence dé lien à cliquer c'est la
même chose on ne clique pas et on se
rend sur le site par sa voie habituelle
donc si je résume on vérifie le ton qui
est utilisé dans le message
l'orthographe est la base de
l'expéditeur c'est tout à fait ça merci
beaucoup à eux seuls avec plaisir à
bientôt
pour protéger nos appareils des
intrusions nos mots de passe doivent
être les plus résistants possible ses 11
1 2 34 non
azerty et vieux mommens later sa date de
naissance c'est quoi déjà bien tenté il
y à là effectivement les mots de passe
les plus utilisés en france nous faisons
tous cette erreur laisser les mots de
passe défini par défaut sur nos
appareils ou choisir des combinaisons
trop simples faciles à retenir on estime
qu'il faut moins d'une seconde pour qu
un cybercriminel crack ce type de mot de
passe prenons un exemple très concret un
mot de passe qui utilise votre prénom
celui d'un membre de votre famille
associé à des chiffres qui ont un sens
pour vous au hasard votre département de
résidence le numéro de votre rue ou pire
votre date de naissance
17 janvier mais oui ces détails de votre
vie privée sont beaucoup trop facile à
dénicher en quelques clics sur un moteur
de recherche ou sur les réseaux sociaux
même chose pour votre équipe de foot
préférée ou votre animal fétiche alors à
quoi ça ressemble un mot de passe
vraiment sécurisé
à ça ou non lors six ans qu'elle nomme
ça je lui dis un mot de passe est long
plus il est sécurisé on parle alors de
phrases de passe écrite en phonétique
avec des caractères spéciaux et des jeux
de mots c'est encore mieux mais le top
de la sécurisation reste le mot de passe
aléatoire plusieurs sites permettent
d'en générer et les smartphones en
proposent de plus en plus une fois qu'on
a trouvé un bon mot de passe on serait
tenté d'utiliser le même partout c'est
plus facile à retenir mais là encore
c'est une très mauvaise idée il suffit
d'un site moins sécurisés que les autres
pour que tous vos comptes soit exposée
aux pirates donc la mesure du possible
un coin un mot de passe
comment je vais faire j'ai jamais su
retenir panique il existe des trousseaux
sécurisé pour stocker ces mots de passe
et puis vous n'êtes pas obligé de tous
les changer d'un seul coup la priorité
c'est de sécuriser son concurrent
personnel c'est la porte qui ouvre
toutes les autres quelqu'un de mal
intentionné obtient ce mot de passe
c'est le jackpot grâce au système de mot
de passe oublié il peut se connecter à
tous les autres comptent onze ans neymar
oui mon vieux
pour protéger son smartphone des
attaques et là aussi c'est très simple
moi je garde mon téléphone sous clé
ces mots pratique pour décrocher alors
c'est une idée avec un code pour
verrouiller son écran ou la carte sim
c'est déjà pas mal et si votre appareil
est équipé de la reconnaissance faciale
ou des empreintes digitales c'est encore
mieux nous sommes accros aux applis en
2021 nous en avons téléchargé plus de 2
milliards mais attention certaines
peuvent contenir des virus ou donner
accès à vos données personnelles
vérifiez bien qu'elle provienne d'un
éditeur de logiciel officiel ou qu'elle
ne vous demande pas des autorisations
d'accès farfelu méfiance par exemple si
un simple jeu de mots croisés vous
demande d'accéder à vos contacts ou à
vos sms en plus et la plupart des applis
continue de fonctionner si on leur
refuse ses accès votre point faible les
ports de recharge de nos appareils quand
nos batteries sont à sec en cours de
journée on est souvent tenté de se
brancher sur l'une des nombreuses bornes
de recharge installées dans les lieux
publics le risque c'est que des pirates
infecte ces bornes et s'en servent pour
espionner les contenus de nos téléphones
pour y installer un logiciel malveillant
le plus sûr c'est donc d'avoir ses
propres batteries de secours
dernier conseil fait bien les mises à
jour elles contiennent le plus souvent
des améliorations de sécurité allez un
petit dernier pour la route ne jouait
pas et codeurs en essayant de débloquer
le logiciel d'exploitation de votre
smartphone au cas souvent au passage des
barrières de sécurité
bien utile voilà avec tout cela vous
avez les clés pour rester connecter en
toute sécurité à très bientôt sur les
raisons et pis curieux la cybersécurité
nous concerne tous
dommage civile
avec mes jeux jamais tout retenir c'est
un cauchemar j'appelle
[Applaudissements]